within a week of being paid all the
money's gone you still have bills to pay
you've scraped and pinched everywhere
you can but there's just not enough to
cover what you need with nothing in
savings no credit cards utilizing poor
credit What alternative do you have
should you visit the dreaded payday
lender
[Music]
payday loans also called cash advance
loans are advertised as a short-term
relief when you're in a financial bind
they are meant to be for small amounts
usually up to five hundred dollars which
the consumer intends to repay with their
next paycheck to some it may seem
enticing to go this route for starters
the application process is pretty simple
only requiring an ID proof of income and
a bank account once the process is
finalized you can get your money the
same day sounds attractive but to see
the real cost we'll have to run the
numbers
Paula has a full-time job as a server in
a restaurant but a bout of covid forced
her to miss several shifts coupled with
the recent increase in gas prices she's
found she doesn't have enough for this
month's rent with the moratorium on
evictions lapsed in her State she
doesn't want to do anything to aggravate
the landlord so she considers taking out
a payday loan it's just 500 she thinks I
should be able to pay that off she
completes the application online
presents the required documents and the
funds are deposited into our bank
account within 24 hours
crisis averted or has it just begun
obtaining a payday loan is easy but the
interest rates are high really high like
Woody Harrelson High Paula's lender
charges twenty dollars for every hundred
dollars borrowed over a 14-day term
that's an annual percentage rate of
around 500 percent after another
lackluster couple of weeks at work Paula
unfortunately only has a hundred and
fifty dollars left over far from the six
hundred dollars she now owes when the
lender tries to automatically deduct it
from her account it triggers a 35
overdraft fee from her bank if she pays
the 100 of interest on the loan the
lender will graciously allow her to roll
over the debt for another two weeks
Paula has already paid 135 dollars in
fees and interest and she's not one inch
closer to paying back the loan it's
estimated by the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau that 80 percent of
payday borrowers fail to pay back the
loan in full within the 14-day term and
that the average loan of 375 dollars
takes an average of five months to pay
back by which time the total cost is
around a thousand dollars That's not
including any late fees or overdraft
fees or Banks or credit unions may have
charged them payday loans are considered
predatory for two main reasons their
High interest rates and the fact that
they do not practice underwriting
underwriting is the process of an
investigating a prospective borrower's
finances to verify whether they will be
able to pay back the loan if you've ever
applied for a mortgage or a credit card
you've gone through it but many payday
lenders don't bother with underwriting
it's almost as if they want customers
who won't be able to pay back the loan
so that they can track them in a
never-ending nightmare of fees and
interest in 2017 the cfpb issued a
mandatory underwriting rule that would
compel payday lenders to check whether a
borrower could handle a loan before
issuing it however the rule was revoked
in 2020 under the Trump Administration
after five months Paula has paid close
to a thousand dollars in interest and
fees without even making a dent in the
original 500 loan she's starting to
realize that this short-term solution
has become a long-term problem so what
can she do assuming she's exhausted her
options for scrounging up extra cash she
could borrow more money like taking out
a personal loan from our credit union or
paying off the loan with a credit card
but most people who resort to Payday
Loans do so because they can't qualify
for other types of credit or have
already maxed out their cards Paula
considers defaulting on the loan after
all her credit score is already in the
dumps but if she thinks the lender will
let her off the hook she's dead wrong
payday lenders will refer to delinquent
borrowers to collection agencies and
even take them to court over sums as
small as a few hundred dollars they can
put a lien on your house or garnish your
wages there is of course the b word
bankruptcy but before she considers that
option Paula should contact the lender
directly and try to negotiate a
settlement lenders would almost always
rather get the money directly from the
borrower than sell the debt to a
collections agency and they're often
willing to settle for as little as half
the full amount especially if Paula
mentions that she's considering
declaring bankruptcy and in which case
they'd get nothing even if Paula makes
it out of this Jam she'll undoubtedly
wish that she'd never gotten into it in
the first place payday loans are almost
always a bad idea if you need cash fast
sell some possessions pick up extra work
borrow from friends and family even take
out a new credit card almost anything
else you can do that's legal is
preferable to a payday loan of course
keeping a strict budget and having an
emergency fund can protect you from even
being in such a vulnerable position
listen we may all find ourselves in a
financial bind at some point and
borrowing money can be a lifesaver when
unexpected crises arrive but you have to
make sure that what you're swimming
toward is an actual Lifesaver and not a
shark in Disguise and that's our two
cents
before you go we want you to know about
an incredibly important new digital
series from PBS facing suicide shines a
light on the power of friends and family
during and after a mental health crisis
here from suicide attempt survivors
their Journeys and explore the healing
found in sharing your story with a group
of peers click the link in our
description to watch it now and we hope
it can inspire you or someone you know
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
[Music]
thank you